the Five Points District in Denver
Colorado has a legacy of
African-American Excellence longtime
business owners like Franklin and
Mandela Steiger take pride in carrying
that torch forward as the neighborhood
changes
the Frank it was made thank you so much
for allowing me to come in here today
when people talk about five points they
always say you have to come see the
staggers
they've been loving you guys for the
past 40 years correct I've been here
before they're better
[Music]
I serve the people who well
and so over the past 40 years how many
people from the community did you employ
here at the barbershop about three off
and on you know in doing my time you had
the natural and the
Jerry curls
and that's what brought
the money in okay Miss May you had a
Jerry girl
yes
did you have a Jacob and a afro I was a
natural okay that was your natural
but then too for the community and with
the projects being over on Arapahoe the
little kids to come in and said Mr
Steiger can I sweep the floor can I do
this no for lunch money and he used to
always have one or two of them you know
come and help clean up the shop and give
them money and they would take that
money and that was their school lunch
money for the week one of the kids that
turned out to be a doctor wow and
whenever he come to Colorado he comes to
the shop thank him I just love that you
guys are such a staple in this community
and you're still here I'm always looking
for ways to support black businesses but
the stigers remind me that it's not just
about buying black these small
businesses are the foundation of their
communities creating the opportunities
role models and healthy environments
that for so so much of American History
black people couldn't find elsewhere
[Music]